you're starting from scratch what do you
what platform do you start on and with
what type of content so I think always
create content where you consume the
most because you're going to know the
format better
try to make tick tocks
it culture the language if you love
YouTube just double down and you can
repost on Tech talk right so double down
to what platform you love the most I
think I would personally start with
YouTube
um and then you can make a hundred tick
tocks or 100 YouTube shorts and focus on
only just understanding how to edit and
produce and be interesting I think a lot
of people focus on how to get views and
optimize when they don't even know how
to talk how to edit how to like get
comfy how to start and just treat your
100 videos as making videos for fun and
I always say like recreate your top 10
favorite YouTubers top 10 videos like
that's a good start like look at if you
like Sean's video maybe to recreate his
top tip actually
you probably get a lot of that but like
you know like start there and you now
you have 100 videos right so make a list
of your top 10 people find the top 10
videos start there and then optimize you
don't need to overthink the beginning
I've always said this but we're living
in the world where topical niches are
already done like if you want to search
how to cook a steak it's a video what's
resurfacing now is combination videos
like a stink of a smoothie right you
combine cooking with a story time that's
that's the meat you know that's that's
what's doing well you think about Alex
Earl a popular tick tock Beauty YouTuber
she combines talking about college with
getting ready and doing makeup the
fusion is how you build an audience the
fusion is what makes you unique there's
already too many videos about how to
surf you know so it's like combine
something else get at that RIS two
things number one I've had too much
coffee today number two if you have not
seen our free master class yet you're
gonna love it if you're serious about
growing your YouTube channel just go to
thinkmasterclass.com for a one hour Deep
dive on-demand YouTube strategy class
it's sick and uh I'm gonna go refill my
coffee hope to see you on the class